>>Mike Oswall: Hello, my name's Mike Oswall.
I'm going to introduce my friend Rafe Sagarin.
Rafe is a marine ecologist and an environmental
policy analyst at the University of Arizona.
He was in my class at Stanford in 1994 and
he has a Ph.D. from UC Santa Barbara in marine
biology.
And he's a Guggenheim fellow.
He was previously at Google.
In 2008 he gave a talk from his first book,
"Natural Security", which he co-edited with
Terry Taylor when they were both here.
That was a very entertaining talk, so feel
free to go back and watch that later if you
like.
Rafe is an avid runner.
Yesterday, he was in Monterey and ran the
Monterey Marathon in 3 hours and 18 minutes.
He lives in Tucson where he runs a lot in
the desert.
He lives with his wife, Rebecca, and their
two daughters Zella and Rosa, and their dog
Raina.
They have a lovely house that's very desert-friendly.
[laughter] He'll be speaking at the Commonwealth
Club this evening and we'll find out when
the broadcast of that will be as well.
And without further ado, here's Rafe Sagarin.
>>Rafe Sagarin: Cool.
All right.
Great to be back at Google.
[pause]
Normally, I walk around a lot, but I'm kinda
stiff today, so I'm just going to hold on
to this pedestal for dear life.
My email is up there.
Often, some of the things I talk about take
a little while to kinda percolate through,
and I get often emails from people a couple
days or couple weeks later, like, "Oh yeah,
wait, I was thinking about this that applies
to things."
Between the "Natural Security" book that I
did in 2008, which was sort of an academic
volume, and this book, a lot of what's gone
into this book are stories from people in
all kinds of fields, from business to soldiers
in Iraq and Afghanistan who have talked to
me about this adaptable process and then gotten
back to me with their stories.
I really appreciate a lot of feedback, and
I really learn a lot in that mode.
[pause]
The basic idea of what I'm talking about in
this book is: how can we learn from nature
about how to be more adaptable?
The way I see it, adaptation is really about
leaving your comfort zone or being forced
from your comfort zone.
So if you think about these earliest amphibians
dealing with a sea full of predators, they
were both forced out of that comfort zone
that they were originally in, but they were
also drawn out by the opportunity that new
niches or new ways of living afforded them.
As for me, my own adaptation into a marine
biologist who talks about national security
and other security issues really started when
I left my own comfort zone.
My own comfort zone has always been tide pools
of the California coast.
This is the Hopkins Marine Station, where
I did a lot of my work.
It's right next to Monterey Bay Aquarium.
My work has been on learning how natural systems
like tide pool organisms are responding to
climate change.
But on 9/11 I found myself feeling very disconnected
because I was down in these tide pools.
I had very close family who were in the capitol
building and other government buildings on
the morning of 9/11.
And less than a year later, I found myself
very far outside my comfort zone, working
for Congresswoman Hilda Solis as a congressional
science advisor.
Ms. Solis' issues -- you may know she's the
Labor Secretary now, but she was just starting
off as a Congresswoman back then in 2002 -- her
main issues are labor and environmental issues,
neither of which were going anywhere in that
particular Congress, which was very much like
our current Congress.
That gave me a lot of time on my hands to
sort of look at the Washington D.C. ecosystem.
As if I were a naturalist, 'cause that's what
I do in my day job: I look at these tide pools
and I try to figure out patterns in them and
really understand them from an observational
sense.
That's really all I could do in D.C., so I
spent a lot of time looking at this ecosystem.
What I discovered in this year wasn't hard
to see was what I call an "ecology of fear".
Everywhere in D.C. at the time you're seeing
New Jersey barriers popping up around, monuments
like fungus in a ring, and you're seeing new
metal detectors everywhere, and new guards
everywhere.
But what disturbed me about it, which was
so unlike the tide pools that I'm so used
to studying, is that these things came up
and then they just didn't change.
Every time I go to those tide pools in Monterey,
where I spent thousands of hours, they're
always different.
They're always changing.
That got me into this mode of thinking about
biological systems and how they always change
in response, say, to the defenses of their
prey, or to the new armaments of their predators.
This is constant escalation and change.
So I thought, "What else can we learn from
nature about how to deal with security threats?"
Right away, I came up against an impasse which
is actually one of the things I really like
about being a biologist, which is that my
biological expertise, such as it is, which
may be condensed to the tide pool life of
the central California coast, is such a tiny
sliver of the massive biological world that
I knew I needed a lot of help to really understand
biological adaptation.
And if I understood very little of biological
adaptation, I obviously understood even less
about security.
What I did is I brought together these massively
interdisciplinary working groups at a place
called the National Center for Ecological
Analysis and Synthesis in Santa Barbara.
It's an NSF funded think-tank, which usually
focuses on bringing people together to tackle
big scale environmental and ecological issues
like "What is the state of the world's fisheries?",
"How sustainable are timber harvests around
the world?", things like that.
But they took a chance on funding my working
group, which simply said, "What can we learn
from nature about security in society?"
I brought together this wide range of life
scientists, anthropologists, biologists, evolutionary
biologists, psychologists, and as well I brought
together a very wide range of security experts,
which were practitioners, which were former
spies, which were public health officials,
and put them all together in a room simply
seated with this question about what we can
learn from nature.
The discussions just took off from there and
became these very exciting discussions where
we touched on just about everything that there
is to look at at the inner face of security
and biological life.
What surprised me after a while of doing this
is that I thought we'd be completely overwhelmed
with the diversity of life, but in fact, we
started to converge on a few fairly simple
rules of nature, rules of adaptable systems,
that I felt we could start to translate into
things we could apply in society.
I'll go through those high level ideas, and
then we'll drill down into the specifics of
adaptable systems.
The basic problem as we see it, the basic
opportunity as we see it, is that nature faces
the exact same problems that all of us do,
which is that risk is completely ubiquitous.
It's almost entirely unpredictable.
All natural organisms have to deal with that,
just like we have to deal with that.
The difference being that nature has dealt
with it for 3 and 1/2 billion years, and it's
been surviving and thriving across that whole
range of biological evolution on Earth.
I'll break that down a little more.
We say that the world is full of unpredictable
risk, but a fish doesn't try to turn a shark
into a vegetarian.
By that, I mean the fish will do everything
in its power to avoid getting eaten by that
shark, but it doesn't implicitly understand
that it can get rid of the threat of predation.
We spend a lot of time in society trying to
assure ourselves, and spend a lot of resources
assuming that we can eliminate risk in our
world.
We declare a war on terror.
We declare a war on drugs.
In my own field, we declare a war on invasive
species, as if we could ever sort of fully
take care of these problems which are actually
just generalized risks rather than specific
things we can do.
The organisms, folks, focus on the specifics,
not on the generalities.
I'll get into that a little more.
Another set of high level ideas from nature
is that nature doesn't plan.
It doesn't predict.
It doesn't try to be perfect.
What nature does is it adapts to solve problems
in its environment, whatever form it takes.
I'll break that down a little bit.
My exhibit A on this point is this very strange-looking
fish called the mola mola, or the ocean sunfish.
If you go down to the Monterey Bay Aquarium,
you can see them.
You have to see them to believe that they're
real.
It's the most bizarre looking fish, but if
I asked any of you to plan a fish for me,
give me a plan for a fish, you would never
come up with a fish that looks like this.
And yet, this has been one of the most successful
fishes on Earth.
It's lived for millions of years.
It's the largest bony fish, because it's exploited
a niche that was available to it.
It solved problems in its environment and
continues to do so.
Likewise, we spend a lot of time and a lot
of resources doing predictive modeling.
Trying to fool ourselves into this sense that
we can predict the future, and then we'll
be better prepared for it.
But nature doesn't do that at all.
Natural selection has weeded out any waste
of resources, trying to predict a completely
unpredictable future.
And as for perfection, we often hear about
the perfection of nature.
If you watch Discovery Channel during shark
week, they'll say, "Here's the Great White
Shark, nature's perfect predator!"
And I always say, "You know what?
It'd be a lot more perfect if it had laser
beam eyes, but it doesn't."
There's no way to actually measure perfection
in nature.
All natural organisms have to be good enough
to survive and reproduce themselves, so it's
survival of the good enough, not really survival
of the fittest.
[pause]
So here's the thing: okay, they do all this
by being adaptable.
They live without planning, without prediction,
without trying to be perfect, just by being
adaptable, and everyone's talking about being
adaptable now.
We always hear, "Oh, that company should have
been more adaptable to changes", "That organization
should have been more adaptable", "This government
agency needs to be more adaptable."
But people don't really understand at the
fundamental level what it means to be adaptable
or how you actually do it.
It just becomes a corporate buzzword: adaptability,
yay.
What I'm trying to do here is break down that
natural adaptability into component parts
that you can then apply into whatever realm
you're in where you have to deal with risk
and unpredictability.
[pause]
The first rule of adaptable systems that comes
to us from this remarkable guy, Geerat Vermeij.
He was one of my working group members.
He's a paleobiologist at UC Davis.
He's one of these amazing naturalists.
He can identify any species.
He is even more amazing because he's been
blind since he was 3 years old.
He picks up a fossil and he can tell you everything
about what it is, how it lived, how it died.
Through this incredible observational sense
and a very broad mind as to thinking about
how trends in biological history have worked,
he has concluded that the most adaptable species
are those that are fairly decentralized.
They allow a number of independent parts to
sense and respond to the environment.
That's one of the reasons the octopus is the
central metaphor in this book because octopuses
are a great example of this.
Octopuses have a wonderful central brain.
They're very intelligent.
They're cognitive.
They think about things.
They can actually think in advance about things.
They probably have a sense of self, which
is very rare in non-human organisms.
Nonetheless, if they're swimming over a coral
reef, they don't have that wonderful central
brain say, "Okay, arm one turn blue now and
arm two turn kinda purple and arm three turn
kinda pinkish."
What they have is millions of skin cells spread
out over their body, each individually responding
to changes in their environment.
By doing so, they give the octopus as a whole,
this sense of camouflage.
This is not unlike our immune system, which
is a bunch of cells running around our body,
looking for invaders and responding to them
without any back and forth to our central
brain.
This decentralized mode in nature is very
common, and it gives you a way to adapt to
changes very quickly.
Now in society, we tend to do almost the opposite
when we're threatened.
After 9/11, the first thing we did was create
the Department of Homeland Security which
is almost the opposite organization.
It's a top down, stacked up organization where
everything has to run up and down this org
chart to get anything done.
We certainly saw this problem in the first
major security test after 9/11, which was
Hurricane Katrina.
The thing was, there everyone's asking, "Where's
FEMA?
What's going on?
FEMA should be here responding and we're not
getting a response."
Well, where's FEMA?
Look at the org chart.
It's down there, buried in this stack of boxes.
These boxes are not trivial little things.
One whole box in this chart is the Coast Guard.
So it's buried in there, nonresponsive.
Another related idea from adaptable systems
in nature is that nature uses redundancy to
solve many types of problems.
In society, we tend to think of redundancy
as wasteful or as inefficient, but it's everywhere
in nature.
Over 3 and 1/2 billion years have to tell
you that there's not going to be a lot of
waste and inefficiency in nature.
It doesn't have abundant resources to throw
at a problem.
And nonetheless, redundancy survives again
and again.
There's simple redundancy in nature, which
like this centipede, has multiple walking
legs all doing the same thing.
That's fine, that gets you somewhere.
Centipedes are fine organisms.
They've survived.
They haven't really diversified that much,
but when some lines of these arthropods became
beetles, they massively diversified.
So much so that about 100 years ago when the
biologist J.B.S.
Haldane was asked, "What do all your studies
of nature tell you about the Creator?" and
he said, "Well, he must have an inordinate
fondness for beetles."
Beetles are everywhere.
They've been incredibly successful because
they turn that redundancy into again what
Geerat Vermeij calls a "creative redundancy"
where individual parts are specialized into
wings for solving problems, into claws and
devices for shooting chemical weapons and
walking legs.
You get this combination in adaptable systems
of multiple ways of seeing a problem with
those independent eyes and independent skin
cells and independent immune cells, and multiple
ways of solving those problems.
That gives you a lot of ways to respond to
unpredictable threats.
[pause]
Here's a shout out to you guys.
A good example of how this would work in society
is Google Flu Trends.
Google Flu Trends maps out when we're all
searching flu-related terms like "Does my
kid have flu?", "What are flu remedies?" all
that.
What you see in this paper that was published
in "Nature" on it is that it tracks extremely
closely to the Center for Disease Control's
flu trends data, with one major difference.
The CDC, big, top down centralized organization,
sends out surveys to doctors and hospitals,
gets them back to Atlanta, has statisticians
crunch through them, and publishes a report,
on average about two weeks later than you
can get virtually the same data from Google
Flu Trends, which is just using those independent
sensors out there: all of us searching on
Google.
Two weeks when you're talking about a potential
flu epidemic is a massive advantage.
It just shows a contrast between that centralized
approach to seeing how the world's changing
to that decentralized approach.
The next major thing is that all adaptable
organisms run up to their limits of adaptability.
When they run up to their limits of adaptability,
they have to reach out to other organisms
to extend what they can do.
This is called symbiosis.
It's various types of partnerships that all
organisms make with other organisms to extend
their adaptability.
Symbiosis is everywhere in nature.
It occurs between the most unlikely of organisms.
For example, this little cleaner wrasse is
swimming into the mouth of a large predatory
grouper to clean out its teeth from parasites.
Symbiosis also creates what we call emergent
properties: things you wouldn't expect from
this immediate interaction.
It's been shown that these large predatory
fish are actually much less aggressive to
all the fish on the reef patch when they're
set up in these cleaning stations that the
little wrasse has made.
Oftentimes, throughout biological history,
long term symbiotic partnerships have emerged
out of relationships that were conflictual.
You have this pattern of conflict leading
to cooperation.
We tend to do the opposite.
We tend to put up walls between our conflicts.
This is the border wall near my home in Tucson.
This is down in Nogales.
But I have seen human symbiotic partnerships
that can blow right through these walls.
An example comes from my partner in this research,
Terry Taylor, who's shown up top here.
Terry Taylor has helped to facilitate partnerships,
symbiotic partnerships.
In this case, between Israeli, Palestinian
and Jordanian doctors and health ministers
who are all working together to identify and
neutralize emerging infectious diseases no
matter what side of the border wall or the
disputed territories that they arise on.
These partnerships show some of the same characteristics
of natural adaptable systems.
Most notably, these guys are not in this to
create peace in the Middle East.
They're not trying to create a perfect solution.
They're looking at the immediate problem and
trying to solve that problem.
That's brought together the energy behind
this symbiotic partnership.
[pause]
Also, Terry has had such success with this
group that he's then replicated these partnerships
in the six countries around the Mekong River,
which are no less friendly towards one another
politically, and now in countries in southern
Africa.
That leads to another system rule of adaptable
systems, which is that the most adaptable
organisms learn from success.
We're hearing a lot of buzz these days in
management literature and organizational literature
about how important it is to learn from failure,
and isn't it great to learn from failure,
and it sounds very self-effacing and clever.
In fact, learning from failure is an evolutionary
dead-end.
It means you die.
It means you don't reproduce.
Learning from success is that seed that creates
a creative, recursive feedback cycle that
leads to all the development of evolutionary
systems.
It leads to continual adaptation built off
a past success.
It's important enough to learn from failure.
You don't want to repeat the same stupid failures
again and again, but we focus way too much
on learning from failure.
For example, in the Townsend after action
report, the government's report on what went
wrong with Hurricane Katrina, there were over
100 different failures identified.
That's important.
You want to recognize "Here's what we did
wrong.
Let's not do this again."
But the most important success of the Hurricane
Katrina response was completely ignored.
We didn't look at what went right.
That success was the Coast Guard cleaning
up a 9 million gallon oil spill.
When would it be useful to have information
about how to clean up oil in difficult circumstances
in the Gulf of Mexico?
Well, in the very next Gulf of Mexico disaster,
which was the Deepwater Horizon.
Because we had focused so much on failure
and trying to learn from failure, we had lost
an opportunity to learn from success in a
way that may have been useful during Deepwater
Horizon.
Taking these ideas together, you can use them
as a spotlight to analyze past situations,
or you can use them as a map to look for it:
how can we become more adaptable going forward?
I'll take a security example as an example:
the spotlight approach.
This is the unfortunate case of improvised
explosive devices killing soldiers in Iraq
and Afghanistan.
What I show in these charts is the monthly
real deaths of US combat soldiers due to IEDs.
In Iraq shown in red and Afghanistan shown
in green.
Here's a case where the Department of Defense,
this big centralized organization, went into
Iraq with a plan, with a lot of predictions
about what it was going to look like.
But it was these grunt soldiers on the ground,
essentially your independent eyes looking
at change and seeing what's going on, who
immediately recognized that the war they were
facing was nothing to do with the plans, nothing
to do with the predictions, but that these
unexpected IEDs, improvised explosive devices,
were going to be the biggest threat to them.
So much so that very early in the war, this
young specialist from the Tennessee National
Guard, Thomas Wilson, whose picture is shown
up there, had the audacity to confront Secretary
Donald Rumsfeld at a big press conference
and said, "You know what?
We're going around, we're strapping hillbilly
armor onto our vehicles", which was scrap
metal.
In other words, these soldiers adapting as
best they could because the vehicles they
had weren't going to do it.
And Rumsfeld tartly retorted, "Well, you go
to war with the army you have" which is a
very nonadaptable statement.
Nonetheless, Congress got word of this, got
very upset, said "We've got to provide armor
for our troops out there, so crank up the
DOD procurement machine."
And in what DOD considered a very fast deployment,
three years later these heavily armored vehicles
known as MRAPVs, mine resistant ambush protected
vehicles, were sent out in the country.
Over those three years, over 1300 US soldiers
died due to IEDs in Iraq.
In the intervening time, soldiers weren't
just sitting there getting themselves killed.
They were doing all sorts of things to try
to adapt.
But it turned out that the most important
thing they did was create symbiotic partnerships
with the enemy.
There were people that were previously shooting
at them, people that were previously making
bombs and putting them out, and soldiers on
the ground and their commanders figured out,
"What do these people really need?
If we can exchange that for a little bit of
peace in our realm and a little bit of information,
we could go a long way."
What you see pointed out here is actually
underneath this curve is more and more intel
from local populations going to soldiers on
where the bombs are.
That peaks right around this time, and right
after that, the IED deaths just plummet well
before these up-armored vehicles came into
the country.
Now we've got these huge up-armored vehicles
that we've made thousands of and luckily enough
for the DOD, things are heating up in Afghanistan
again, so let's send those vehicles over there.
Well, a 15-25 ton vehicle can go almost nowhere
in Afghanistan.
It had some mobility in Iraq, but there's
very few roads that can handle these vehicles
in Afghanistan.
If you're in the Taliban and you've got a
1 ton Toyota pickup truck, probably the most
adaptable vehicle ever made, you can go anywhere
at will and you also know exactly where the
US forces are going because they are limited
to certain routes.
And Taliban then start using the IED approach
and being unfortunately quite successful,
learning from their successes, and getting
more and more successful killing with IEDs.
Now for thinking about taking these ideas,
moving forward, one stumbling block for a
lot of people is this idea that we're totally
different from the rest of the natural world.
I continually try to point out the fact that
yes, we are different, we have a wonderful
cognitive mind that's better than any other
organism, and we're extremely social and that
has given us a lot of power to adapt, and
that's been really good, but we're not that
different in the end.
We have the same genetic architecture and
we do the same fundamental things.
For example, one of the things that we do
that all living organisms do since the beginning
of biological time is organisms have to identify
what is like themselves and what's not like
themselves.
It's called self-nonself recognition.
It takes on all kinds of different forms,
whether you're a bacteria or a salmon, for
which it takes on the form of having a really
good chemical sense of your home stream, so
much so that you will battle your way past
anything to get back to that home stream to
reproduce and then die: essentially a suicide
mission to send your genes onward.
Based on this self-nonself recognition system.
Now in humans, it's much more complex.
It's behaviorally mediated, but it's the same
thing.
It's the same reason why we develop such strong
group identities, identities that are so strong
that in extreme cases, we'll kill ourselves
for a cause if we believe it will benefit
our group.
Evolution goes beyond, in humans, just the
simple "replicating my own genes", but it's
also mediated in group dynamics.
All that is to say that we are this evolutionary
species.
We've actually been an incredibly adaptable
species for most of our existence on Earth.
And yet we've buffered ourselves almost through
our successes from the relentless push of
evolution.
The question is: how can we start becoming
adaptable again?
Taking these systems we have, that have become
somewhat unresponsive, and making them much
more adaptable and responsive again.
I never say anywhere in this book or anywhere
I talk about like, "Yeah, we've just got to
tear down the Department of Homeland Security"
or "Tear down the Department of Defense and
build them up as this adaptable organization"
because I'm not into perfect solutions.
Nature isn't into perfect solutions.
What you want to do is identify problems within
those organizations, within your own organization,
within your own lives, and figure out: how
can I solve that problem more adaptively?
The main shift that needs to happen is to
shift from a mode of giving orders to issuing
challenges.
Giving orders is when a small group of experts
or a single leader, single organization says,
"This is what you all need to do.
Follow me."
Issuing challenges is when you say, "Here's
a problem we're all facing.
Who among you can help us solve this problem?"
An early precedent for this is in the 17th
century.
Ships were crashing all over the place because
no one knew their longitude at sea.
It was a huge problem.
Everyone thought, "Oh, our great astronomers
will figure out how to navigate using astronomy
so that we'll figure out our longitude."
But rather than relying on that, English Parliament
issued a challenge.
They said, "Anyone who can solve this longitude
problem: we'll give you a big prize."
It turned out it wasn't an astronomer, but
a watchmaker who figured out if they could
make a very accurate chronometer that could
keep time very accurately at sea relative
to the home port, you could calculate your
longitude.
That's what solved the problem there.
[pause]
The thing about challenges is they're not
just if they're done right.
They're not just a one-time thing that gives
you some good solutions to a problem.
They can be set up to be a perpetual adaptive
machine or what I call an "adaptive cascade"
that goes from activating these independent
sensors, which is what happens when you issue
a challenge broadly and a whole bunch of people
are trying to respond to this problem.
And that gives you these multiple creative
redundancies that you want.
So you get a lot of different solutions coming
from all over the place, not just the astronomers
but the watchmakers out there.
That creates opportunities for symbiosis.
You have someone responding to part of a challenge
and saying, "Why, I could really knock this
thing off if I just work with someone like
this to figure out the challenge."
It creates a natural seed for symbiotic partnerships.
If the challenges organize correctly and if
the incentives are in place in the right way,
you get this learning from success because
you reiterate challenges, maybe make them
more difficult the next generation, and take
those successful designs and put them back
into this machine so that overall, you get
this system that is continually generating
new adaptive responses.
And so I'm going to close with a few quick
examples of how this is being done.
You've probably heard of DARPA's grand challenges.
Here's a small arm of the Department of Defense
that, instead of trying to develop some new
technology by going to a single contractor
and waiting 30 years and going over budget
by bazillions of dollars and getting something
that doesn't actually solve the original problem,
which is the case time and time again with
military procurement programs, they just go
out and say, "Here's a challenge: design us
a completely remotely operated vehicle."
I know that that's recently been merged into
the Google vehicle idea.
Those are challenges that attracted a ton
of attention.
They started several years ago.
The amazing thing, which is important to recognize
about challenge-based problem solving, is
the prize initially for their first grand
challenge was $1 million.
That's what I call couch change to the Department
of Defense.
Probably most of the respondents spent more
than $1 million responding to these challenges.
When the challenge is designed right, people
want to solve the challenge.
It does not take a lot of resources to make
it work.
3M discovered this, so 3M is by no means some
kind of huge adaptable great company that's
an exemplar of how to make an adaptable company.
They're a pretty traditional company, but
when they wanted to reduce their environmental
footprint, they didn't have the CEOs say,
"Everyone recycle 20% more.
Do it."
They had a challenge where they said, "Anyone
who can reduce our environmental footprint
in any way, give us your ideas."
So you had administrative assistants over
here saying, "Oh yeah, we could reduce a lot
of paper if we did this" and you had chemists
over there each responding in their own little
part of that world and saying, "Oh yeah, we
could reduce our chemical waste a lot if we
just reconfigured these fume hoods" or something
like that.
3M got over 8,000 different successful responses
to this challenge, saved them hundreds of
millions of dollars.
They massively reduced their environmental
footprint.
And really all employees got for participation
was a certificate.
Again, not a lot of motivation needed.
We've seen it in the environment.
Instead of having the government say, "All
fishermen reduce your by-catch" -- that's
a wasteful species that are caught that are
not the targeted species, that fishermen have
to throw back, usually to die, because they've
taken up their nets.
Environmental groups and fishermen groups
issued a challenge: $50,000 to anyone who
could come up with better technology, gear
technology, or ways of fishing that will reduce
your by-catch without reducing your value
catch.
This is a challenge that's gone on year after
year, so you're getting better and better
designs, and they're coming from the people
who are experiencing the problem out where
the problem is occurring, not back in Washington
where the rule makers are.
Finally, as a last example, in my own classes
as a professor, I have for years been putting
up this mocking diagram of the Department
of Homeland Security and chuckling about it
with audiences: "Look how inadaptable that
is!"
And then I realized, "Wait a second.
My classes look just like the Department of
Homeland Security" because in a typical class,
if the circle is me as a professor, and the
triangle is the class period, I'm bringing
in a little bit of information.
Information I've decided on.
I'm feeding that into the classroom.
[pause] [noise in background] It's really
noisy.
[pause] I'm feeding that into the classroom
and all my students are expected basically
to follow what's going on.
And I wonder why most of my students are checked
out.
I get a few Chatty Cathy's who are talking
all the time, and then the rest are just texting
under their table.
So what I started to do is go into class on
the first day of the semester and I rip up
the syllabus.
And I say, "You know what?
You guys all took this class on marine conservation,
say.
You want to know something about it, and I
don't know exactly what that is, so you tell
me what you want to know about marine conservation,
and you also tell me what you can share with
me about marine conservation.
We'll build the class from that."
The first day, we build the entire semester,
what we're going to talk about.
I have students leading every class period
with some lead topic.
For every class period, I have the rest of
the students put on a riff off that main topic
onto a course wiki site.
So there might be a main topic, and then students
just, before midnight, on the night before
class, have to add something: a YouTube video,
a paper, some personal experience that they
had that relates to the main topic.
What happens then is you get a class that
looks like this.
Now the class is gathering information from
all kinds of different sources, not just the
one or two that I've selected for that day.
But we're getting government reports, we're
getting artworks, we're getting personal experiences,
more literature, we're getting information
from other professors, other classes they
took.
It's all feeding into this class, and I'm
just sitting out here on the side, not really
needing to do everything because everyone
in that class is fired up and ready to talk
about it.
This idea of just ripping up the syllabus
and letting those independent sensors work
on the problem, if you will, is exactly the
same as going into a meeting and ripping up
the agenda, and saying, "We're in this room
together.
If there's a reason we should be in this room
together, let me know what it is.
And if not, let's not have this meeting."
The other little tricky thing about that,
the reason I have a syllabus in the first
place, is because my dean requires me to have
a syllabus.
That's the last lesson about imparting these
adaptable ideas into a system that may not
be so adaptable: you want to do it like a
virus.
Like a virus that has a protein coat when
it comes into the body which is protecting
it from an immune response.
Like a cloak.
You want to sneak in there, get it started.
By the time you're discovered, you're proliferated
enough that you're beyond reproach.
I've run these classes for several years now.
I dutifully put in my syllabus.
But I've also been evaluating them every year
with an independent evaluation so that now,
when my dean finally discovers that I've been
ripping up the syllabus, I have a body of
work and I can say, "Look, I've learned from
my success every year.
The students love this kind of class.
They're way more into it.
My evaluations are off the charts."
That's how you want to build it up, rather
than trying to break it all down to begin
with.
This is exactly what soldiers in Iraq and
Afghanistan that I talked to did.
They did a lot of things that were outside
the standard operating procedure.
But they cloaked what they were doing until
they were successful, and then they shared
that success with other commanders.
And it started spreading like that.
The basic idea here is that it's not just
about security.
It's about anywhere where the future is unpredictable,
where there's risk, that using ideas from
nature about how to be adaptable can be extremely
helpful.
There's lots of other examples in the book
and on my websites there.
And I'm happy to discuss them with you now.
Thank you so much.
[applause]
And I think there's a microphone because we're
being filmed, if you have questions.
[pause] [water bottle opening]
>>male#1: I'll start with--.
Hello, I'll start with one quick question.
Did you do all of the drawings and sketches
for your presentation?
>>Rafe Sagarin: Yes, I used to [laughs] I
used to use Google images to steal my drawings
and images from the internet.
I don't know if any of you do that.
But I discovered that I do have some paid
speaking gigs, and suddenly my life of being
within what I consider fair use at the university
and in various talks that I usually give didn't
seem quite so justifiable anymore.
So I just said, "I'm just going to draw my
own stuff so it's copyright -- so I own the
copyright."
And that has been a long process because,
let me tell you, it's been a lot of years
of downloading images from Google.
I'm building up back a legal library of images
to use.
>>female#1: Hi, I'm Alex.
[laughter]
>>Rafe Sagarin: Alex, you have a question?
[laughs]
>>male audience member: I love Alex!
[laughter] [pause]
>>Rafe Sagarin: Yeah.
>>male#3: I'm curious to hear how, as you've
been learning in the book, and just, I guess
studying this, what the policy makers' reception
has been?
And I think some of what you hear in the past
about the counter-insurgency during war has
been about being a lot more adaptable and
listening more, so you can already see some
of this stuff but I'm just curious now what
the reaction you've gotten was.
>>Yeah, so the question was, "What's the reaction
from policy makers and such?"
From the very beginning of this project, which
was quite a few years ago, to the present,
I have been getting an unbelievably positive
and enthusiastic and interested response,
especially from policy makers and people who
are on the ground dealing with security threats
because, again, they've all been hearing this
charge.
Some of them have been ordered to be more
adaptable.
And yet, they don't really know where to start
with that.
So I've really tried, especially in this book,
to put it into terms where you can do it no
matter where you are in an organization or
where you are in your life.
You don't have to be the Secretary of the
Department of Homeland Security to implement
these things.
You can be the kind of middle manager that
I frequently talk to.
Just by changing into this challenge-based
mode, you can start to inoculate these ideas,
so I've got actually a very positive response,
especially from the security world.
Yeah.
>>male#4: So, you talked a lot about adaptability
and a lot about dynamic systems, but it's
not really clear what exactly the definition
of adaptability is.
I mean, we have a naive understanding of it,
but I can't really think of a formal definition
that fits in with everything.
>>Rafe Sagarin: Yeah, you can make a formal
definition for adaptability.
There's been a bunch.
It's changing in response to changes in the
environment or something like that.
But I much prefer to define it by showing
how it's been done in many different cases
over billions of years, because part of getting
value out of the concept of adaptability is
to see all the diverse ways in which adaptable
systems have used it.
A ground squirrel does it completely differently
than an octopus, but they both run around
these same basic themes of decentralized approaches
and how to use information and how to use
symbiosis.
It's a simple concept, just changing in response
to a changing environment, but it's that diversity
underneath the concept, and the fact that
that diversity coalesces around a few key
themes that makes it such a powerful concept
for use.
[pause]
You think you want to ask another question?
[laughs] Yeah.
>> male#5: I guess one question is about the
speed of adaptability or the speed of change.
We think about the Department of Defense,
or RIAM, or Google as fairly large organizations
who take a long time to adapt.
Species generally take a long time to adapt.
You could argue the octopus changes in a few
minutes underwater.
As you mentioned, there's different ways of
defining adaptability, but it seems like it
can often take centuries.
I guess I'm curious to hear how organizations
often just don't have that kind of time on
their hands.
>>Rafe Sagarin: I'm glad you raise the issue
of the timing of adaptation, because there's
a lot of misconceptions out there.
We often think of adaptation as this huge
multigenerational thing that will only be
apparent once you look back in millions of
years at the fossil record.
But in fact, like most biological systems,
and I talk about this in the book a lot, biological
systems are nested in every way.
The same kind of things you see at the genetic
level occur at the cellular level, at the
organismal level, at the ecosystem level.
They're nested, and it's likewise nested in
time.
Adaptability occurs on all these different
nested time scales.
It occurs virtually instantly.
It occurs fairly quickly like the octopus
changing color.
And yes, it occurs over multiple multiple
generations.
But the more we've looked into, as biologists,
adaptable systems, the more we're understanding
that it's spread across this full spectrum.
We're just learning, right now literally,
that even our genetic structures are adapting
in real time and doing some very radical changes
in real time with gene jumping kind of things.
So there's really no limits on the timing
of adaptation.
[pause]
All right.
Like I said, please contact me with other
ideas.
Some of them will pop up as you read the book.
Please tell your friends about it.
Thanks for coming.
[applause]